Mais s'ils plaident coupables, ils deviendront des criminels.
Même si une personne riche ne sera jamais dans cette situation
parce qu'elle paiera sa caution.
Vous vous posez sans doute la question
de savoir comment je peux vous inspirer.
(Rires)
« C'est très déprimant. Je veux qu'on me rembourse. »
Mais en fait,
parler de ce sujet est moins déprimant que son alternative.
Si on ne parle pas de ces problèmes,
si on ne change pas notre vision commune de l'incarcération,
in fine, nos prisons resteront remplies de pauvres qui n'y ont pas leur place.
Et ça, c'est super déprimant.
Ce qui m'enthousiasme dans ces histoires, c'est qu'elles nous poussent
à envisager la prison autrement.
Non plus en ces termes stériles que sont l'incarcération massive
ou la condamnation de contrevenants non violents,
mais en termes humains.
Mettre un être humain en cage pendant des jours, des semaines,
des mois ou des années,
quel est notre impact sur son esprit, son corps ?
A quel prix sommes-nous prêts à infliger ça ?
Si nous tous dans cette salle, nous engageons
à penser à l'incarcération autrement,
alors, nous pouvons rendre anormale cette normalité.
J'espère pouvoir vous quitter avec l'idée
que, s'il y a bien une chose fondamentale à changer,
je ne parle pas uniquement d'une réforme du système des cautions,
c'est de faire en sorte que ce qui remplacera l'ancien système,
ne punira ni les pauvres ni les marginaux d'une autre manière.
Si nous souhaitons un tel changement,
nous devons commencer par changer notre propre vision.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)